شكرا لكم اني انا جمعت فيكم من زمان والله
زمان والله زمن بداياتي كانت مع مع راويه
اول مره اول ما اجيت على على دبي من
الكويت كان عشان نقدم صباح العربيه مع بعض
انا كان فتره عم بقدر بخمسه
اقدم صباح العربيه لا انبسطنا كثير انا
وعادل وعادل طبعا اللي ما بيعرفوا دمه
خفيف كتير كتير عنده روح النكته فطول
الوقت وانا قاعده جنبه واحنا قاعدين
بنقدمه انا يعني راح اموت من الضحك دائما
الحياه سعيده اذا ما كانت سعيده لابد ان
نراها سعيده يوم احنا نحتفل يمكن انا واحد
من الناس اقول انه كانت في بداياتي اول ما
اجيتي الى دبي مش في ال2005 جيت قبلها قبل
انطلاقه العربيه ايضا كان في شهر اكتوبر
اعتقد او نوفمبر
كمراسل
بالكويت صحيح اي قبل انطلاقه العربيه حتى
كان في اجراءات انه بالجزء هذاك ممنوع انه
ندخل نشوف
اللوك او الشكل الجديد
للعربيه وكان استديو الاخبار المذيعين
كانوا يعملوا دائما هذه يعني
خلينا نقول التمرين اللي هو ما يسبق
الهواء وكل شيء اختلف ما بعد
لا
بعدك لو سمحت شباب الصبايا